non
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui paris saclay
tv vous emmène au muy med mu pour musée
met pour médiathèque c'est le pôle
culturel de saint quentin en yvelines
le tout nouveau musée de la villa vient
de rouvrir ses portes l'occasion de
redécouvrir l'histoire de votre
territoire
une histoire qui se construit jour après
jour comme ce réseau intelligent de
chaleur et de froid mise en place sur le
campus de paris saclay les deux
premières stations ont été installées
l'innovation elle est aussi au coeur de
tech'innove une convention d'affaires
lancée il ya onze ans maintenant que
faut-il en retenir notre équipe était
sur place
vous connaissez le proto 204 se plaisent
tout mis sur le territoire et peut-être
que vous n'avez jamais eu l'occasion le
temps d'y aller
et bien il ira bientôt à vous grâce à
son proto bus enfin n'oublions pas nos
trains jada les temps forts des semaines
à venir ce sera à la fin de cette
émission on commence cette émission avec
une visite guidée du muy med mu pour
m'user med pour médiathèque c'est le
pôle culturel de saint quentin en
yvelines il abrite aussi le théâtre
évidemment
venez découvrir le tout nouveau musée de
la ville un espace aménagé et interactif
pour redécouvrir l'histoire de votre
territoire
[Musique]
et
le musée de la ville a deux aspects un
aspect qui porte d'ailleurs le label art
et histoire qui est donc toute
l'histoire du territoire depuis la
commanderie des templiers
le musée de port royal royal des champs
révolution avec versailles est donc dans
ce territoire
c'étaient les portes de du grand parc de
versailles
et puis après il ya eu toute l'histoire
de l'arrivée de la sncf en particulier
sur sûre et rap et la création des
villes des villes nouvelles et donc la
création de 50 au niveau
donc là on retrace toute l'histoire et
en même temps avec tout ce que l'on a pu
récupérer sur les plans et sur les
maquettes pour voir l'évolution de
l'urbanisme et dans cette partie
historique on met en lien tous les
objets de vie on met toujours un objet
de vie qui était qui correspond à la
période de mon très étudié on peut
consulter de la documentation
il ya des petits films qui peuvent être
visionnés et c'est ça c'est donc la
partie permanente de ce musée en
parallèle il y à une exposition
temporaire qui change à peu près tous
les ans et qui lui elle est liée à
l'évolution des modes de vie dans les
modes de vie on voit aussi bien les
vêtements que les objets ménagers que
les meubles et à partir de ce moment là
on fait des expositions temporaires on a
une collection énorme à ce musée que ce
soit la partie temporaire où que ce soit
la partie permanente on mais aussi des
visites sur site et on a aussi tout à
fond documentaire où toutes les
personnes qui sont intéressées peuvent
avoir peuvent avoir accès on est plus
effectivement lié avec tout ce qui est
évolution des modes de lui dont
l'innovation que un vrai musée
historique voilà pour l'histoire le
patrimoine votre territoire innove et se
construit au jour le jour il devient éco
durables notamment avec la mise en place
d'un réseau intelligent de chaleur et de
froid sur le campus paris saclay nous
vous avions parlé de ce projet ambitieux
il ya quelques mois les deux premières
stations ont été installées tout de
suite les explications de pierre antoine
picard de la société idex
on est ici dans le local technique les
bâtiments de l'école centrale
le bâtiment a qui est situé sur la zac
du moulin un des premiers bâtiments qui
est alimenté en chaleur et en froid
sur la zac ainsi que le bâtiment b qui
aujourd'hui alimenté aussi depuis
quelques quelques jours on a derrière
moi une installation type de livraison
de chaleur et de froid par des échangeur
à plaques qui permettent d'alimenter
l'ensemble du bâtiment avec de l'eau
chaude et de locon 10 classes et l'eau
chaude
areva 60 degrés l'eau glacée est ainsi
degré et permet de répondre à tous les
besoins en chaleur et en froid du
bâtiment cette installation est assez
caractéristique aura retrouvé la même
dans tous les bâtiments qui sont
raccordés
elle est plus ou moins grosses en
fonction des besoins de du bâtiment ces
installations pour fonctionner elles ont
besoin d'être raccordés au réseau
raccordés au réseau qu'est ce que c'est
c'est à dire qu'il ya des canalisations
qui traverse le bâtiment et puis qui
circulent en voirie pour les rejoindre
les installations de production donc là
en terme de réseau de canalisations
environ 60% des canalisations sont posés
en varient mais les travaux sont pas
réduits à ça il ya aussi des travaux de
préparation qui seront lancés pour
pouvoir réaliser les forages sur chacune
des 2 ac
les forages c'est
d'appui au total deux baraques et ses
travaux commencent au mois de février et
vont se terminer à la fin de la neige
travaux assez long pour aller chercher
la ressource de la nappe de l'albien
quitte à 700 mètres de profondeur au fur
et à mesure de la livraison des
bâtiments il faut les alimenter en
chaleur et en froid en fonctionnant
besoin aussi en eau chaude sanitaire et
donc pour la fin du mois de mars de
nouveaux bâtiments qui sont prévues sur
le programme serendipity
et puis à fin mai début juin juste avant
l'été à d'autres bâtiments de paris
habitat qui sera des logements tout
comme ceux de serendipity qui eux seront
donc alimenter en chaleur froid et le
programme de raccordement ne s'arrête
jamais puisque d'ici la fin 2010 et
atteint d'autres bâtiments et puis en
une série d'une quinzaine de bâtiments
qui sont prévues est alimenté en chaleur
en froid et en eau chaude sanitaire
poule en passant
l'innovation est au coeur de tech'innove
une convention d'affaires lancée il ya
onze ans déjà par la cci essonne
le principe est simple réunir le temps
d'une journée les principaux acteurs du
territoire qu'ils soient chercheurs
investisseurs ou encore entrepreneurs la
nouveauté cette année le startup
challenge la suite avec jean-claude
chabat c'est le président de tech'innove
à
c'est la onzième édition de tech'innove
c'est une manifestation convention
d'affaires qui a été organisée par la
cci essonne depuis 2007 12 cette 11e
édition et qui réunit
sur un même endroit et dans un seul jour
trois conventions une convention
d'affaires donc qui réunit donneurs
d'ordres preneur d'ordres une convention
de laboratoire enfin r&d qui réunit donc
des laboratoires et des pme qui sont
intéressés par les recherches effectuées
dans ses laboratoires et une convention
de financement
donc on a des jeunes pousses qui sont en
recherche de fonds propres pour un
premier tour de financement de ces trois
conventions permettent en fait aux
participants de d'afficher un programme
de rendez vous lors de rendez vous
qualifiés c'est ça tout l'intérêt de
cette manifestation c'est que en fait
aussi bien
celui qui demande que celui qui reçoit
ont décidé de se rencontrer pour un
intérêt commun cette année nous avons
fait une innovation particulière c'est à
dire on a créé un startup challenge
puisque effectivement un grand focus est
donné sur les start up qui sont l'avenir
de notre développement économique
et ces startups donc on fait candidature
pour ce challenge qui réunit maintenant
26 start up sur trois thématiques
immobilité énergie et objets connectés
nous avons sélectionné 26 start up pour
venir pitcher dans une salle qui leur
est dédié devant un parterre dans
d'entreprises intéressées non seulement
elle pitch mais en plus elles ont été
préparées accompagner pour effectivement
maximiser finalement l'impact de leurs
messages
aujourd'hui tech'innove
c'est plus de 900 structure donc pme
grands groupes laboratoires qui sont
réunis aujourd'hui c'est plus de 1700
personnes
et dans ces 900 structure il ya 400 pme
160 grands groupes 80 laboratoires
donc autant de structures qui trouvent
un intérêt à se réunir ensemble au même
endroit et en même temps qui ne connaît
pas le proto e 204 ces deux places to be
sur votre territoire
une plateforme de création de formation
d'innovation un lieu des changes
bonne nouvelle si vous n'avez pas eu le
temps ni l'occasion d'y aller
eh bien le proto 204 viendra à vous
grâce à son proto bus
le projet prend forme tout de suite les
explications de françois moser
le proto bus il est né en fait de la
rencontre entre deux acteurs le pea
paris saclay et transdev donc le pea via
le proto 204 l'idée c'était de mettre en
fait l'innovation au service de ce vaste
territoire qui est paris saclay et de
pouvoir propager la dynamique
d'innovation qui se crée au sein du
proto de 104 puis pour un groupe comme
transdev c'est vrai que le proto bus
c'est aussi l'idée de rapprocher
l'innovation aussi de territoire que
nous nous desservons puisque transdev on
est un opérateur du territoire de
paris-saclay on décerne notamment le
campus urbain et un certain nombre de
lignes de transport public sur la région
le bus est actuellement en chantier on
est en train de réaliser l'aménagement
intérieur
on est également en train de mettre en
place tous les équipements
technologiques que l'on souhaite
remettre à disposition dans le bus et on
travaille également à tout ce qui est
homologuée à sion du nouveau véhicule
donc toutes les démarches
administratives pour pouvoir faire
circuler le bus je l'espère dans deux
trois mois maximum
ça met à contribution un certain nombre
de nos collaborateurs qui réalise
l'aménagement la maintenance du véhicule
donc c'est déjà un petit projet
d'entreprise en soit à l'échelle plus
global pour le groupe
on est sur un territoire assez unique en
termes d'innovation et avec un axe fort
autour de la ville durable
donc c'est vrai que pour nous en tant
qu'acteur justement de la ville qui
servant à animer aussi ce territoire aux
côtés notamment de le pea ou dès que des
collectivités c'est l'occasion en fait
de créer une plateforme est de
rassembler des gens pour parler de
nouveaux projets d'aménagement de
nouveaux services de mobilité qu'on
pourrait mettre à disposition d'une
manière un peu différente
ludique et en même temps probablement
plus participative en tout cas c'est
l'ambition qu'on a avec ce projet et
c'est vrai que ben on est un groupe on
essaye de plus en plus de collaborer
avec nos usagers pour mettre en place
ces services ça va être vrai aussi je
pense par exemple au tour du véhicule
autonomous et des nouvelles technologies
mais aussi un peu d'imagination et
d'innovation sociale et je pense que le
proto bus c'est aussi l'ambition qu'on
souhaite donner avec le proto 204 c'est
ce côté à la fois techno et ce côté
social proche du territoire
autres temps forts à venir dans votre
agenda le mipim
c'est le plus grand salon à destination
des professionnels de l'immobilier
il aura lieu du 13 au 17 mars et
n'oubliez pas l'inauguration du jardin
argenté au sein du campus paris saclay
c'est le 23 mars à 10h30
voilà c'est fini pour aujourd'hui rendez
vous le mois prochain pour un nouveau
paris saclay tv d'ici là restez informé
sur notre site au pap est ce point fr à
bientôt
[Musique]